hasta qué edad tendremos que trabajar si
ustedes son elegidos uno y otro sean
honestos ambos han cambiado sus
opiniones sobre este tema y los
franceses ya no entienden bien qué es lo
que propone cada uno marín de penn para
ser claros usted si es presidenta
a qué edad
tomarán su jubilación al final de su
mandato si usted es elegida entre 60 y
62 años para recibir una pensión
completa tendrán que haber pagado 40
entre 40 y 42 anualidades
filosóficamente considero que el sistema
de protección social es el bien de
quienes no lo tienen es el patrimonio de
quienes no lo tienen se expresa por la
solidaridad nacional es algo
fundamental para la quinta república y
no se puede tocar esto para no tocar las
instituciones de la quinta república y
en este sistema de las de protección
social las jubilaciones
son muy importantes y mientras más se
trabaja hay que jubilarse más temprano
por eso propongo un sistema progresivo
todos los que hayan tenido un primer
empleo significativa antes de la edad de
20 años entre los 17 y los 20 años todos
ellos podrán tomar su jubilación a los
60 años después de haber pagado 40
anualidades y progresivamente en función
de la edad a la que se entra al sistema
se alcanzará un máximo de 42 anualidades
y 62 años es muy diferente del proyecto
del señor maicon que quiere hacer que
todos trabajen hasta los 65 años
permítanme recordar porque sé que los
amigos del señor vacuna han querido
crear una duda respecto a esto todo
dispositivo particular carrera larga y
otros serán prioritarios con respecto a
mi reforma si alguien gracias a un
dispositivo de carrera larga tiene un
beneficio que le es más ventajoso por
supuesto que el sistema de carrera larga
será el que se aplique pero a la
jubilación de los 65 años es algo
injusto es alguna injusticia
insoportable señor marco pensar que los
franceses
tomen la jubilación cuando ya no son
capaces de disfrutar
sabiendo que la mayoría de ellos ya no
están en la actividad porque ya a los 60
y 28 años ya la mitad de ellos están
inactivos cuando toman la jubilación
pensar bien nadie pueda tomar una
jubilación plena porque ya nadie llegará
a esa edad con el número de anualidades
que por supuesto aumentará también usted
lo sabe si se aumenta la edad de
jubilación por supuesto también se va a
aumentar el número de anualidades que
deben haber pagado realmente no hemos
entendido muy bien